visitez des vignes dans les yvelines cet
été c'est possible domaine de la bouche
du roi situé à d'avron dans la plaine de
versailles organise des circuits avec
dégustation des vins du mercredi au
dimanche
l'occasion de découvrir cette production
c'est un solide ça a été une très grande
région viticole avec plus de 40 mille
hectares de vignes au 19e siècle et
aujourd'hui grâce aux évolutions
climatiques on a pu replanter un
vignoble qui nous permet d'amener des
raisins à maturité ici et donc on
découvre dans un paysage très diversifié
un vignoble de 25 hectares d'un seul
tenant
donc c'est assez effectivement
originales et insolites de pouvoir
surtout ensuite goûté la typicité de
celles qui viennent d'arriver en
production depuis deux ans cet été le
domaine propose également un circuit qui
mêle visite dégustation de vins et
produits locaux appelés mets et vins est
proposée au tarif de 49 euros
on a derrière nous la table des
différents produits qu'on a choisi pour
aller avec n'aura donc on a
dès qu une cuvée qui va avec la truite
fumée de la pisciculture de ville est
qu'on commence à déguster avec un de nos
blancs mon ancienne ensuite avec une
bouchée de caviar d'aquitaine déguster
avec le chemin de la cuvée legrand levé
qu'on présente en 2d et ensuite on passe
au rouge avec un fromage de la ferme de
tremblay qui a un saint jacques à la
sauge très parfumé et on finit avec une
dernière cuvée en rouge et du chocolat
de la chocolaterie cola qui est une
entreprise voisine située à mol à la
rentrée d'autres activités insolites
seront proposées avec notamment des
cours de danse dans le domaine en
partenariat avec le cabaret le lido
les visiteurs pourront également
apprendre les travaux de la vigne en
septembre et en octobre pendant les
vendanges la structure espère recevoir
plusieurs centaines de personnes tout au
long de cette saison estivale